the federal government's handling of
rules around truckers and vaccination
status is now causing some to blow the
horn organizers and participants coming
from across the west with a strong
message drop the mandates across the
board for every single man woman and
child across canada we've dealt with
this for two years you said two weeks to
flatten the curve we're two years later
earlier this month ottawa made
vaccination mandatory for truck drivers
crossing the border the u.s followed
suit which has launched the convoy
despite the canadian trucking alliance
disapproving the demonstration
supporters have chipped in more than 3.4
million dollars for a gofundme campaign
to help pay for the journey it's
divisive we're really really alienating
big pockets of our population with some
of these mandates and whether it's
justified or not
it's hard to say this bioethicist says
he's unsure whether the science
justifies vaccine mandates but that
government communication has ultimately
put canadians at odds ipso's polling
done for global news found two-thirds of
people believe stricter measures should
be put on unvaccinated people it also
found that half think government should
put a health tax on people who are
unvaccinated
a conservative party leader was asked
whether he would meet with truckers when
they arrived on parliament hill but
didn't answer the question the new
measures ultimately mean up to 26 000
fewer truck drivers are able to cross
the border aaron o'toole says that could
lead to fewer items on shelves and
higher prices so we can't have policies
that make that even worse and we can't
raise taxes so
that's what we've been advocating for
responsibly the last few months the
convoy is expected to reach ottawa later
this week
kyle benning
global news